can you uh
dig in a little deeper like what is uh
dmt
how long is the trip usually like how
much do we understand
about it is there's something
interesting to say
about just the the nature of the
experience and what we understand about
it
one of the common methods for people to
use is to is to smoke it or vaporize it
and it usually takes and this is a
pretty good kind of description of what
it might feel like on the ground
um and the caveat is it's it's
it's it's a completely insufficient
description and someone's going to be
listening to it it's like nothing you
could say is going to come close
but it'll take about three big hits
inhalations in order to have what people
call a breakthrough dose
um and there's no great definition of
that
but basically meaning moving away from
you know not just having the typical
psilocybin or lsd experience where
like things are radically different but
you're still basically
a person in this reality to go in
somewhere else
and so that'll typically take like three
hits and this stuff comes on like a
freight train
so one takes a hit and around the
time of the first exhalation so we're
talking about a few seconds in
or maybe just you know sometime between
the first and the second hit
like it'll start to come on and they're
already up to
say um you know what they might get from
a 30
milligram or or 300 microgram lsd trip a
big trip
they're already there when at the second
hit but it's they're going their
consciousness is gear this is like
acceleration not speed to speak of
physics okay it's like
you just those receptors are getting
filled like that and they're going from
zero to 60 in like
you know tesla time yeah and
at the second hit again they're at this
maybe the strongest psychedelic
experience they've ever had
and then if they can take that third hit
even some people can't
they're i mean they're
they're propelled into this other
reality and the nature of that other
reality
it will will differ depending on who you
ask but
you know folks we'll talk often talk
about and and and we've done some survey
research on this
entities of different types elves
tend to pop up yeah all the caveat is
i strongly presume all of this is
culturally influenced you know
but thinking more about the psychology
and the neuroscience
there is probably something fundamental
you know like
for someone that might be colored as
elves others it might be colored as um
terence mckenna called them
self-dribbling basketballs for someone
else it might be little animals or
someone else it might be aliens
i think that probably is dependent on
who they are and what they've been
exposed
to but just the fact that one has a
sense that they're
surrounded by autonomous entities
right intelligent autonomous entities
right and people come back with stories
that are
just astonishing like there's
communication
between these entities and often they're
telling them
things that that that the person says
are self-validating but it seems like
it's impossible
like it really seems like and again this
is what people say
oftentimes that it's
it really is like downloading some
intelligence from a higher dimension or
some whatever metaphor
you want to use sometimes these things
come up in dreams where it's like
someone is exposed to something that
i've had this in a dream
you know where it seems like what they
are being exposed to is
physically impossible but yet at the
same time
self-validating it seems true like that
they really are figuring something out
of course the challenge is to say
something
in in concrete terms after the
experience that
where you could um you know verify that
in any way and i i'm not familiar of any
examples of that well there's a there's
a sense in which
i suppose the experience is like um
you uh you're you're a limited cognitive
creature that knows very little about
the world and here's a chance to
communicate
with much wiser entities that
in a way that you can't possibly
understand are trying to
give you hints of deeper truths
right and so there's that kind of sense
that you you can take something back
but you can't where uh our cognition is
not capable to fully grasp the truth
we'll just get a kind of sense of it and
somehow that
process is mind expanding that there's a
greater truth out there
right that seems like what from the
people i've heard
talk about that's that seems to be what
uh it is and
that's so fascinating that there's um
there's
fundamentally to this whole thing is a
communication between an entity that is
other than yourself entities
so it's not just like a visual
experience like uh
like you're like floating through the
world is there's other beings there
which is kind of i don't know i don't
know what to
sort of uh from a person who likes freud
and carl jung i don't know what to think
about that
that being of course from one
perspective it's just you looking in the
mirror
but it could also be from another
perspective like actually talking to
other beings
yeah you mentioned young and i think
that's he's particularly interesting and
it kind of
points to something i was you know
thinking about saying is that that
i think what might be going on natural
from a naturalistic perspective
um so regardless you know whether or not
there are
you know it doesn't depend on autonomous
entities out there
what might be happening is that just
the associative net the the the level of
learning
the the comprehension
might be so beyond what someone is
is used to that the only way for the
nervous system
for for the for the aware sense of self
to orient towards it is all by metaphor
and so i do think you know when we get
into these realms
as as a strong empiricist that i think
we always got to be careful
and be as grounded as possible but i'm
also
willing to speculate and and sort of
cast the nets wide
with caveat but you know i think of
things like archetypes
and you know you know it's plausible
that there are certain stories there are
certain
you know we've gone through millions of
years of evolution
it may be that we have certain um
characters and stories that are sort of
that our central nervous system are sort
of wired
to tend to yeah those stories that we
carry those stories in us
right and this unlocks them in a certain
kind of way and we think about stories
like our sense of self is basically
narrative self is a story
and we think about the world of stories
this is why metaphors are always more
powerful than
um you know sort of laying out all the
details all the time you know
speaking in parables it's like if you
really get so you know this is why
as much as i hate it you know if you're
presenting to congress or something and
you have all the
the best data in the world it's not as
powerful as that one anecdote as
as as the mom dying of cancer that had
the psilocybin session
and it transformed her life you know
that's a story
that's meaningful and so when this kind
of
unimaginable kind of change and
and and experience happens with
dmt um ingestion
it these stories of entities they might
they might be that you know
stories that are constructed that is the
the closest
which is not to say the stories aren't
real i mean i think we're getting into
layers where
it doesn't really right yeah yeah but
it's the closest we can come
to making sense out of it because i do
what we do know
about these psychedelics one of the
levels beyond the receptor is that the
brain is communicating it with itself in
a massively different way
there's massive communication with areas
that don't normally communicate
and so it i think that comes with
both it's casting the nets wide i think
it that comes with the insights
and and helpful novel ways of thinking i
do think it comes with
false positives you know that could be
some of the delusion
um and so
you know when you're so far out there
like with dmit experience like maybe
alien is the the best way that the mind
can
wrap some arms around that
you